uh
so in your uh history hyenas that
unfortunately has come to an end
yeah we're talking about empires coming
to an end all empires fall
yeah um that one um
oh it may rise again empires might rise
who knows
who knows i i'm obviously a fan so i
hope it does
rise again but you've uh seemed to
develop your own language
can you uh you know it's what it is
what is what is that what the hell um
is this some kind of medical condition
or can you can you
explain like the linguistic essentials
that uh
uh catch us up to the linguistic
essentials that people need to know
to understand the way you speak you ever
you know leopold and loeb you know the
story of those two
uh they murdered that kid and they had
this weird relationship
uh anyway it's an interesting thing to
google leopold and love these two guys
who ended up murdering a kid because
they developed their own language with
each other and uh this whole reality and
this
weird thing and they wanted to know what
it's like to murder a kid in a murder
kid it's a famous story in american
lore and history whatever famous case
um but this phenomenon yeah me and chris
got together
it wasn't as dark as leopold though we
didn't murder a kid but
we murdered a podcast
or at least stabbed it a few times yeah
it's um it was something
in the organic chemistry of me and chris
that i think we'll both
end up uh appreciating even probably
more than we do now
that uh it's mysterious i gotta be
honest with you
it's um it was the thing that
it wasn't conscious uh wasn't
intentional
it was something that happened in the
music of our energies
yeah that just went it's fascinating
like when you hear someone sing or
when a jazz band hits a rhythm or even
when i'm on stage and i just
catch a rhythm it's like dude i didn't
make a choice there i don't know what
that is i don't know how to explain it
but it comes from somewhere else and uh
i don't know what it is
it's beyond my comprehension but with
chris
uh there was this magical chemistry that
uh you know i have chemistry with a lot
of people
and uh it can be funny and i feel zero
chemistry here this is great
yeah it's a little bit more intelligent
than what me and chris did uh
but you know uh me and chris uh i think
we connected in in
on on the funny bone like i he i found
him so funny
and we found the same things funny and
from that
these organic expressions came from the
some part of our brains
that was created from this chemistry and
yeah we just developed this in
language in this cult following and
people were really upset
when we ended but it was the right thing
to end because
like all things that end it was kind of
done a few episodes even before we
finished and
i think we pulled the plug before it
started rolling downhill
like all uh you know like all great
flings you know there's a long
relationship
long marriages are boring and
comfortable
the one you really like [ __ ] always
ends abruptly and sadly and uh but you
always look back and you jerk off to it
and uh but so you guys made love we made
yeah so it's like it was like a hot
fling
with me and him and it was intense and
we
burned the candle at both ends and it
was me i think that podcast was meant to
be
three years and um maybe people will go
back and appreciate it and
listen to it over and over again and i
think the new things we do people will
love i i'm doing long days now that
podcast and people seem to enjoy i'm
really enjoying the long days yeah yeah
on youtube i just found myself just like
staring
at you uh ranting for same with tim
dillon i really enjoyed the whatever
those rants are the genius of just
one thing after the other but definitely
the chemistry
almost as a study i remember the reason
i first started listening to it i was
trying to get
an a perspective on certain historical
moments
like it was interesting i tuned in to
learn history
yeah i i came for the history and like
stayed for the
the chaos and crack open and clean out
and yeah this it was almost i listened
to rogan
like this sometimes i'll i'll re-listen
to an episode
uh to to try to understand
why was this so fun to listen to
it's it's almost like trying to analyze
humor or something like that but
it's nice from from a conversational
perspective like why was this so easy to
listen to
and then and uh with history hyena is
like why is the chemistry so good
it's it's so it's weird it's weird uh
because there's not many
podcasts like i don't know any with
chemistry like that
yeah it's interesting and it's kind of
sad that uh that
that the the fling with a prostitute in
vegas has to end
you know like that but that's what makes
it special it's the bokowski thing with
the fog
the the british office one of my
favorite shows was
was that it ended very quick you know
it's only a couple seasons or something
like that
and that was tragic but that took guts
to just end it
given all the money you could have made
given all the you just end it and that's
what makes it like truly special
yeah and i'll tell you man i'll just
emphasize it because i marvel at it too
um because as a guy who tries to always
figure out
uh what the causes of things i gotta be
honest man looking back on that even
with retrospective wisdom you know that
2020 hindsight we've been done a couple
months now
it's um it's something that i can't
explain
yeah it's something that i don't know
how you quantify it i don't know how you
describe it
it's it's musical it's really kind of
rhythmic
so maybe maybe like a netflix show about
history
that's that's another that that's in the
future
with the two of you yeah who knows you
you guys will meet like
uh with that the way you meet with the
fling like
a decade from now at a diner and uh
you're both way fatter and uglier and
and then you just reminisce
over some cigarettes and coffee that
could be yeah it could be
yeah but uh it's definitely a classic
podcast that people can go back and
appreciate
it's fast-paced and it was unique what
was it like to research for uh
i mean it was really scholarly the the
depth of research that you performed
uh it sometimes felt like you almost
read an entire wikipedia article
beforehand
or like exactly true uh we were we were
one a fan we attracted such
funny people to that podcast and the
fans were so funny
and one fan called us nicknamed those
wikipedia [ __ ]
and so it just stuck yeah we just would
read wikipedia i would do a lot more
research to chris
yeah and uh so i would actually uh you
know once in a while he'd get into it
too but
for very interesting episodes i got i
got some some
some subject matter would just pull me
in like bernie madoff just to think of
one that was recent it was one of our
last ones and i think one of our better
episodes
and i'm glad that uh it kind of ended
after that because it was rare
i think we started to slip a little bit
um i got fascinated and i got i did a
lot of research for bernie madoff but
usually yeah we'd pull up wikipedia and
we'd have fun we were sort of the
antithesis of dan carlin i mean you went
to dan carlin
for uh accuracy and thoughtfulness and
you went to us for
it was a hang with history that's why
history hyenas was such an appropriate
name
because it was it was a little bit of
his some some episodes were more hyena
more wild and a little history and some
were a little more dense like the battle
of crete and les hyena so
you were you were always going to get
both you're either going to get a
majority of one or the other yeah and
dan carl is the lion i guess
and uh you guys predictably good
uh i mean what what are your thoughts
about i mean he's a storyteller too he
gets a lot of criticism for the
from the historians quote-unquote that's
why he likes to knock
he keeps saying he's not a historian but
what's your uh
what are your thoughts about hardcore
history with dan carlin like we'll see
an inspiration to
the podcast you were doing uh or
or like an account like uh almost like
reverse psychology inspiration
where you wanted to do some kind of
opposing type of podcast in history
or was history always just like a
a launching pad to just talk [ __ ] about
human nature
more the latter i wasn't even aware of
his podcast when we started oh
interesting yeah and um
so we it was just very organic again
like the chemistry me and chris
became very good friends we started the
podcast
first we did a web series called bay
ridge boys which has its sort of little
cult following he did like five episodes
and ended it um and then we did the
podcast
and uh hyenas were my favorite animal
and i talked about them passionately and
i told chris about them and then he
started appreciating him
and we both love history i majored in
history it's one of the things i love i
go to museums all the time i go to his i
do history tours so does he
and so it was just sort of a natural
let's do a history podcast and it gave
us something to talk about each episode
to sort of lean our you know hang our
hats on and
riff off of so it had nothing to do with
dance what i think about dan's i think
it's great
i think even if he's inaccurate uh in
the opinions of the historical community
it starts conversations
which is good it's like this thing where
people go oh it's dangerous rhetoric
it's like no
rhetoric only becomes dangerous when
education fails what's going on in
america is education has failed
so if you call someone online dangerous
it's not him that's dangerous
it's the [ __ ] stupid people that's
dangerous and it's the fault of this
country we didn't listen to aristotle
the future of a civilization depends on
public education
yeah and we failed education has failed
kids are kids are not interested in [ __ ]
and um so in some sense those uh like
dan's podcasts and
podcast can be incredibly educational
that's he's uh
the storytelling that pulls you in
ultimately leads to you internalizing
these stories and like remembering them
and
and thinking through them and all those
kinds of things that is much more
powerful than any
book on history that's accurate i think
often it inspires you to go learn more
so it's like i know we did that i mean
you know i people would go hey i went
and learned about this because they knew
with us there was no pretense which was
great
that we had no standard so it's like
nobody came to us for historical
accuracy
but i was kind of turned on by the fact
that it
inspired people to go learn about this
stuff or to at least know like battle of
crete like you said a very
underappreciated battle um even winston
churchill said uh from here on we will
no longer say
that uh greeks fight like heroes but
heroes fight like greeks i mean it was a
monumental battle and um you know not
talked about
enough and i i i our podcast would
inspire people to go actually learn
more to go listen to dan carlin or to go
pick up a book or to do research on
their own and so
i think podcasts dan carlin's obviously
much more accurate than us but
it's good that people are going to
podcast like yours and
to learn [ __ ] joe was is really like
the progenitor of that i mean you know
having intellectuals on and
getting the public interested with this
new medium
um in in people who are intelligent
it's nice because you know what the
mainstream press pushes out is horseshit
gorgeous horseshit it's got a beautiful
veneer
but no substance and so this this is a
nice pushback
yeah the authenticity of joe's show i
mean i'm through i started listening
from the very beginning you know doing
my in grad school
you know like a technical person and he
just pulled me in
and made me curious to learn about all
kinds of things
and use my own critical reasoning skills
on some of the
[ __ ] guests he's had and some of the
most inspiring guests he's had so
teach you to think
you